Well, first of all, this prompt doesn't match what we want the user to do
anymore. That's a bit better. We also need to check more things about the
value. If it's too low or too high, we keep asking. Too low would be that value
is less than zero. And too high would be if the value is greater than 100. If
either of those is true, we want to keep going. Let's test this out and make
sure that the edge cases work well too. It's asking me to enter an integer
between zero and 100 inclusive. If I enter something like 101, it'll keep
asking. That's good. Now, if I enter something like negative one, it still
keeps asking. That's also good. But it should accept zero and 100. Looks like
it accepted zero. Let's try running it again. Will it accept 100? Looks like it
accepted it. So this was the correct condition to check the user's input.